how do you how do you battle the inner
embarrassment
you know it's the weirdest thing when
it's when it's on camera and it's it
feels like it's for research purposes
literally yeah
to the point where
and part of the humor and entertainment
comes from me being embarrassed which
makes me less embarrassed
that makes sense yeah i do videos in
japan similar thing yeah i worked in a
strip club recently yeah yeah i i did
not see that one specifically
okay are the strip clubs that are
different
uh yeah a little bit i guess i mean i
haven't been to any here oh oh maybe you
should tell me for research
for research you have to be able to
answer my question
i must go to a ship
yeah i mean that i i feel like yeah when
you're on camera it kind of gives you
like a free pass to just yes
embarrassment yeah yeah not good
i realized that the other day i went to
this uh this bar and i never
there's there's this social anxiety
that's just like uh-uh immediately like
cut off any opportunity to to feel like
out of my element yeah right so i went
to this thing i was like i'm just gonna
push myself to do it and i was like
why i was thinking i was like i could
totally do this if cameras were on me
and if it was like i'm like
talking to the camera i'm gonna be going
this thing i'm gonna be uncomfortable
let's see what happens yeah i would be
able to totally do it yeah and i was
trying to
reframe my mind to be like can i trick
myself into
there is a camera following me and i'm
doing this for research purposes because
i would be a pro i would be a pro at
anything invisible
it's my invincibility
i'm like i could do anything if a camera
is on me i don't know it's weird tell me
you're a youtuber yeah you're just like
concentrating like through influencers
it empowers you it feels like you have
like a pass to just do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah like oh no don't worry there's a
camera on him that's right yeah
like if these cameras were not rolling
and we were all just sat down up there i
feel like it might have taken us an
extra 10 minutes to warm up you know
it's weird right there's like this
invigoration you almost feel from being
on camera yeah because like normally
like most my content is not on camera
and the only time i started going on
camera was like for this podcast and
like at first i was like really really
awkward and it was just really really
weird being there but then you kind of
get used to it and it kind of becomes
your friend right and it kind of becomes
like it'd be kind of
because part of the entertainment factor
comes from whatever happens yeah yeah
yeah so you're forced to lean into this
yeah and the people around you as well
as soon as they see you being being
filmed they're like okay they could they
can be a bit of a monkey you will
absolutely get a free pass i'll tell you
what is like the real free pass though
so you sometimes in japan we have like
we bring like the camera crew but for
some reason every time we've brought
like a boom mic that is that is when
like people around us know that shit's
going down
yeah yeah because they they you know
they see like a shotgun mic yeah they're
like oh well you know this is just like
a hobby for someone you know just
filming for their friends
but when they see a massive boom like
they're like oh this is real [ __ ] right
like this is like yeah they got a crew
yeah yeah excuse me gentlemen do you
want some coffee
they immediately think we're like more
important than we actually are yeah when
they see the boom mic yeah we don't even
use it mostly we just use lapel
microphones yeah yeah yeah it's just
like it's relaxed yeah
free card uh but i i was thinking back
to i was like there were there have
definitely been moments of things that
i've shot that i would be so embarrassed
if the cameras weren't rolling and i uh
i did this video i spent a day with
anime cafe maids
and i i said if this video gets over 100
000 likes i will become a maid and i
will
make a documentary about me doing a show
and i actually put it on put the show on
with the girls that i had interviewed
yeah and i looked back at that and i had
the most confidence in the world like
zero bit of embarrassment about
literally stepping on people and having
my full-on ass cheeks out yeah so i was
like if the cameras were not rolling i
would have been like i don't want this
attention
yeah something about the uh knowing the
cameras are there and i'm trying to you
know almost like i'm working like i'm
[ __ ] working here guys like something
about that i was just like it's okay
yeah it's like it's like a little devil
that's sitting on your shirt yeah like
don't worry it's for context
i don't know if that's a good thing i
don't know if that's a good thing just
like a professional through and through
you know it's it's like you know when
you're an actor and the director says
you know [ __ ] yeah what did they say
again [ __ ] actually action
oh you need to know this
i'm sorry okay i'm sorry it's only been
five days in l.a okay
i i feel like like when i go into a lot
of the videos i'm like i will never get
a chance to do this again like you can't
make it true yeah you can't make a like
you could do the video again but you
can't really no no it'll never be the
same reaction no one's gonna click it
again or they will but you know
it's not the same it's not the same yeah
i i was having a conversation um with
someone recently and
i was trying to figure out why i feel
like i'm in such a different headspace
when i'm conducting an interview right
part of it is that i've done a pre-call
part of it is that i know where the
conversation is going to go to a certain
degree but also
in many ways i feel like
it might be it's like the last
conversation i'll ever have with this
person not to say that like i'll never
talk to them or whatever again but for
some reason there is like this is this
one moment yeah in a way it feels like
there's all this count yeah yeah and
even though there's a lot of pressure
it for some reason the fact that it
feels so dire it almost alleviates the
pressure in a weird way right yeah
knowing that you can kind of go for this
the deep questions yeah yeah yeah like
this is your one shot yeah yeah like
what you were saying right right yeah
when you started did you ever feel like
i guess nervous being too intrusive or
you know kind of like diving down a bit
too deep yeah a little bit i mean i
would tell people beforehand like if
there's any question that you don't want
to answer like don't ever feel like i'm
trying to pry further than you're
comfortable yeah like i would tell them
like tell me to not
going down in direction that you're not
comfortable with but now that i do the
pre-calls again that that removes most
of yeah sometimes i'll drill down a
little bit further but for the most part
i see if they're comfortable and i try
to word the questions in a way where
they can tell me as much as they want or
go in as much as they want sometimes
they'll tell me something if i want to
get in deeper i'll be like oh and i'll
kind of rephrase what they just said to
me yeah which
sounds really stupid if you like if we
just leave it in it's me saying the
exact same thing that they said but for
some reason hearing it back i feel like
they know that i understood and then it
gives them the opportunity to
to refine or dig in deeper if they want
yeah so usually it's like i kind of
throw out little invitations to go
deeper without feeling like i'm prying
in okay right so it's like it's like
their choice if they would like to go
down if they want to yes yes right
exactly that's pretty small today yeah
it sounded like you're describing uh
yeah
so like obviously like you see it's like
a massive interview series on youtube
now but you came off of this like off
the back of smosh what made you want to
start doing this series was it did you
want to explore a bunch of ideas and
then this was the one that like kind of
stuck or was it always this that you
wanted to do well i mean you know smosh
was definitely a
comedic like
silly
thing so i never thought that i was
going to get into
any deeper conversations like connecting
with people in the way that the series
is now um and the whole series kind of
started off as a joke of course the very
first video when i left i was like okay
part of the joke was that i'm an
independent youtuber now i have no idea
what's going on i mean it was i'm a
strong independent youtuber i was
feeling feeling myself um and it was
actually very true i didn't i had not
uploaded my own video in years because
my company had taken it over all right
so part of the joke was like hey what
what is a
youtuber independent youtuber do now and
i was asking for advice and i uh
interviewed a bunch of popular youtubers
and there was something about that
dynamic of having a conversation where i
didn't know where it was going and the
funniest moments were the ones that were
improvised rather than 100 scripted yeah
and i really enjoyed that and then later
on it was like let's
revisit and i was like struggling for a
long time just floundering like what do
i do with this channel and every every
single week it was like i don't know
what to do okay i figured it out okay i
shot it okay i hate it so now i'm gonna
figure something else out okay
now i'm releasing this thing that i
don't really like but i ran out of time
yeah and uh
eventually i was like what were the
things that i liked doing most on the
channel so far let's uh you know i'll
dial in deeper with those ideas and then
i started expanding on it from there
yeah yeah man japan needs to start like
listening to how you do your interviews
because you would hate how interviews
are done in japan i don't think i've
ever heard a japanese interview tell me
about oh god do you guys get interviewed
like on japanese
when you infuse anyone you have to give
them the exact script
there's no room for yeah and they will
sometimes have scripted answers about
what they will say to you back so
everything is pre-planned there is yeah
you are not allowed to go out of like
off script
and it's just the most rigid interview
you could like ever imagine is it like
that in different places of asia as well
because i have made i've also
interviewed someone from south korea
um and it was a similar thing right
well they were speaking english to me
and it was obviously not their first
language so it's like of course they
want to know what they're saying yeah uh
they wanted the questions beforehand uh
and i i figured yeah they want to know
what i'm saying to them just in case a
word slips by that they don't know yeah
but i didn't realize what they were
doing was scripting their responses to
such a degree that afterwards they sent
me their script yeah
and oh wow and whenever uh i i thought
it was a little bit weird at the moment
whenever i asked a question they would
repeat the
answer that they had already said and i
was like okay well they were a lot more
loose in the pre-interview just talking
about all these things
and then here i was like maybe they're
just nervous or something okay i get it
people get nervous yeah but then they
sent me a script and it was verbatim
every single word that was said yeah i
think they had a teleprompter yeah i
think like because i i've done quite a
bit of interviews with like industry
people in japan and like a lot of them
are like okay send me your list of
questions beforehand we will approve all
the questions we will write up like a
very basic thing and i'm like okay
that's fine but i've done enough now
where i'm just like okay we'll follow
your script but i'm gonna add extra
questions yeah yeah and you won't be
prepared for them and so i can really
catch you out on what you actually feel
and for the most part they're okay with
it when it actually happens but i think
if you tell them beforehand hey by the
way i'm going to throw in some extra
questions they'll just freak out yeah
because they'll be like we're not
prepared their teams will say like yeah
their teams will be like no you can't do
that but when i do it on the day of the
recording and i get a good answer and a
good conversation flow going then
they're like oh
maybe it's okay yeah maybe it's actually
maybe it actually makes for an
interesting interview
they're not out to [ __ ] me over yeah
exactly maybe they actually are just
like genuinely interested in me want a
good interview i wonder how many people
have to be screwed over
like in order for that to become thus
like how many bad interviews what have
you done
to get to that point yeah yeah but it
does take a while to kind of build up
that rapport that rapport and that level
of uh respect or trust yeah yeah with
people you know and i've i've seen that
too i i'm i have people that are a lot
more comfortable with doing my
interviews now than i think that they
probably would have been a couple years
ago before i'd really
um you know i don't know if i want to
call it proven myself but like i guess
proven that i'm not going to purposely
and maliciously try to like
defame someone and ruin their career you
never really showcase even like you know
what most people consider strange things
you never really show it it's like whoa
look at this weird thing you're just
like these are real people let's just
see why real people do what they do yeah
if it is a strange thing i i like to
talk with them about how well yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly and the
thing is most people
are absolutely willing to talk about how
something that they do is strange
it's not like they are so like
in a different world that they think
everyone should do this and if they
think it's weird then [ __ ] you you know
what i mean yeah yeah
but you've probably you've had people
like that though right in the past in
which way in the in the sense of like
them trying to prove a point and being
like no you're weird for thinking that
this is weird kind of a little bit but
it's still it still seems a little
playful they're like normies don't get
this
so so they they still i think recognize
that but yeah definitely people are a
little bit defensive but i think it's
because they've been shown enough times
that they
like they almost they feel like they
have to be defensive because that means
that someone doesn't respect them and i
think it's just a lot of like vying for
respect of people yeah
yeah do you often find like do you ever
find people that it's it's it's a
different field where you're just
talking to someone casually but when
you're in like in an interview setting
with cameras you really have to like
make them feel comfortable like being
themselves and talking like do you did
you find that a challenge with your
interviews at all just getting people to
be comfortable on camera as quick as
possible a little i mean yeah you bring
up a good point i i do obviously have a
limited time and i can't just spend the
first like hour of the interview warming
up yeah yeah yeah i
i
i go out of my way to really connect
with people um you know we we have the
pre-interview call so there's a little
bit of that dynamic where we're already
laughing together and we already are on
the same page so there's that when they
show up but of course they're a little
bit more tense but
i you know i'll meet the guests on the
street i'll walk them in i'll bring them
out to the back we do our covid tests
and we like hang out
uh you know like on this park bench that
i have on my balcony and we just chit
chat and uh i i get to know them and i
you know tell them a lot about myself so
right
i think that there's there's like a
method to
kind of warming people up to so that
they can see like that you're genuine
and that you're not secretly going to be
trying to get it one up on them you
should have done it
i should have taken them out back
down anthony just turned up we were like
all right camera's on
let's
now we used to do something similar we
called it like i don't know i don't know
if it was a strap but the denny strat so
we there was a denny's outside of our
office yeah often out like invite them
to like lunch beforehand yeah like get
to know them have a casual conversation
but one issue we always
found ourselves having was we'd get into
a conversation and it would just be like
[ __ ] this is this is good material
i mean it literally happened like the
five minutes since we sat down and we're
like [ __ ]
let's just like not ask any questions
this is like good material that we can
get yeah
yeah yeah and that's part of the
challenge also i mean that's
the closer you get to someone the more
you start connecting with them the more
you start talking about things that are
then difficult to bring back up and have
it feel like the first time you talked
about it yeah but that's what helps
having my my questions
already yeah because we actually go away
from those conversations for a little
while and then
if we have a good conversation uh you
know i'll write it down in my notes i'll
be like this is a good we need to bring
this back up again right yeah smart we
should take notes yeah we should
definitely take you out this isn't a
podcast we're just literally just asking
for advice now
how do you do it you guys didn't have to
get i could have just sent you a message
where were the questions